every vertical product today in the
market and it requires
the ability to translate what you know
into actual products um
so in protantics basically what what we
want to do today is to allow those
electronics in the simple words to
communicate with us during both the
production and using the in in the usage
in the field
and to tell us what hurts them and
how they feel from like the deepest
level of electronics before a failure
possess
like an elementary threat i would say to
the safety
of the driver
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hello at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet gal
carmel executive vice president general
manager automotive protein techs
gal is an automotive entrepreneur with a
proven track record of over 15 years in
rapidly honing emerging technologies
markets and opportunities both on
business and diverse r d aspects before
joining protein techs gyal served as
chief technology and production
engineering of samsung smart machines
building from the ground up samsung's
adas and av technology focusing on full
stack platforms for automated driving
systems prior to that he held key roles
in some of the most innovative pillars
of autonomous driving and mobilized
acquired by intel a leading supplier of
advanced driver assist systems including
the first production of monovision
camera aeb autonomous emergency braking
reaching 5 star euro end cap rating for
the most advanced production programs
oems
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm great thank you for having me it's
great to be here i'm i'm really excited
to talk about automotives in a really
really deep and awesome way
and and in general about you and about
your life you've had some some
incredible incredible things from being
an entrepreneur yourself and and working
in in a variety of companies but then
being r d program manager at mobileye
and chief technology and production
engineering samsung smart machines
europe and israel and then transitioning
to being an executive vice president and
general manager of the automotives at
protean tx and so um you know
crazy background
make sense of it for me who are you
oh um
interesting question i think that um if
i'm trying to translate who i am to
oppose to who i was
and people certainly asked me
um how was as a child compared to today
i'm actually saying that uh pretty much
the same but smaller
so i think i grew up in uh in really
encouraging
electrical engineering and electronics
environment my father is also
coming from electrical engineering
and i think i was always fascinated um
i think by the depth and knowledge that
you need to be able to acquire in order
to build cars
so it evolved so many aspects mechanics
physics electronics design and then back
then i still didn't figure out what it
requires in order to actually driving
those machines
my first car didn't really start so i
spent most of my time fixing it
to get to the air force base i wasn't
allowed to drive a motorcycle back then
today luckily i drive both motorcycles
also build them mainly disassembling um
because i don't have much time i really
like it but when you're talking about
you know fixing what are we talking
about because i barely know how to
change the tire myself so we're not
we're talking about like more advanced
things even right
yeah yeah so um
you know this is uh this is a hobby and
that will uh um
later take us to the question how the
future will look like if you're gonna
fix a bike in or a car in in ten years
but today's just using a torque wrench
playing with it and
you know trying to to be creative and
and what it is uh
uh that you do assembling parts
disassembling parts um
and uh keeping in touch with the
mechanics is always great
right so you know that you know that's
you as a kid now how do you explain that
what what you know what is it about your
personality or about your interest what
was it that you were specifically
interested in you know automotives or or
was it there was a greater you know
pattern to sort of the way that your
your brain is wired or that the thinking
that you that you have on a day-to-day
basis
yeah so
i think i'm being called uh very
analytical i'm coming from really
engineering background and i see myself
as as engineer very value driven i would
say and i always loved
advanced technology but not only the
technology part of technology i love to
see how technology is actually being
translated
to product and then deployed um in the
real world
which is very interesting to see things
coming from idea to usage especially by
by driver i love difficult problems
um and personally i focus in
in things that would produce a change in
the world that i would love as a person
um to see
right
so walk me through
you know the remaining part of the
journey and i want to reach you know
that your current and your current role
as executive vice president of
automotives
you know what what how does your career
look and sort of what are the skills
that you gain personally
and later i want to also touch on your
understanding of the automotive market
and and where we are today and where we
should be headed
so i think i i i always wanted to be a
pilot but i discovered that some of the
things are really better to do i think
as a hobby but i started my career you
know printing cvs and trying to get to
wherever i can saying
i'm smart give me a chance and i spend
most of the time in startup vision and
optics and object tracking after that
building chips
and i think i scaled up my vertical
knowledge um through the stages from
electrical to software to application to
to to product
um but if i'm putting like a real
emphasis of i think the juncture in my
career it's um i think mobilize
back then when a job mobilized was
a beeping machine
so i think it was really touched my
synergy point combined
um my engineering button up background
and the top-down understanding of of
uh the product and what driver would use
in scale
in the market um so i was super lucky to
spend with mobility through the two
pillars of uh
of autonomous driving the first one was
the first autonomous emergency braking
the first time that the car with the
mono camera actually breaks in front of
pedestrians um and car
back then it was only on premium oem
today it's standard feet and you can
find it and also going to find it in the
future in every car so that was the
first really pillar of sensing of
autonomous driving
um then the second one was a project
called ram it's the first time that
actually car
communicated with the cloud using data
so it's the first time that cars send
data to the clouds aggregate data for
mapping and for localization it's
basically open
a huge opportunity in the market for a
data-driven approach for sensing
um i think the post the ipo i moved to
samsung i served as the
cto of a group called
driveline
which basically the target was
building semis to aid us building a
semiconductor to aid us in in the shape
of full stack
especially focusing on really advanced
nodes
and processes in the market
and i think that was the first time that
i really saw from an entrance price
perspective what it requires
um
to build a chip to the automotive
market and how it looks like from a
enterprise point of view
um
once i think when we finished that uh
that project uh that was my decision to
move from enterprise back to startup
this is my court is what i love to do
i'm always focusing in automotive my
entire uh my entire career
and i think that and that was the point
that they met shy cohen and the former
melanox team that basically live and
breathe uh semiconductor
um
they were backed up by uh by world
leading investors with a really proven
track record like um
viola kdt intel capital and later on
porsche and vw a part of the vw group
and they were super experienced in the
data center world and it was amazing to
see how we're taking the product from
data center and communication
um to automotive okay awesome so so gal
you know you're you're finishing your
time at samsung you've had a quite a run
at mobileye
where's your head at before you decide
to go into your next journey how do you
see the automotive industry and and what
really excites you
in the place that you're at
um so at that point i definitely know
that what i want to continue doing is
something that is around cars
um
[Music]
i said that car are a great thing not
only on the practical level but but what
i see um
at the market at that stage is that
they're currently going through
a very interesting evolutionary process
that on the one hand it's teaching them
new language new language that is
communicating between cars and clouds
and chips
but on the other end around they become
a very dense environment
of advanced electronics
um
now what happens because of that is that
the reliability of the cars the
electronics inside the cars towards us
as drivers and oems
um actually decreases the age on the
road um and the control of how you you
repair them basically moves from the
private sectors to the big manufacturer
of who if you're gonna ask them um they
also uh lost
in troubleshooting especially in real
time finding what's going on inside the
machine
you can simply compare it to a washing
machine that in the past was composed
from three parts but today it has a full
brain and if something goes wrong you
basically look at that and say
okay what's going on
and i thought what's going to be in the
market with
companies or cars that is fully
electrified fully electronic take tesla
for example you cannot take it to a
workshop in tel aviv and just lift it up
and say
okay i know what's the problem you don't
have engine you don't have gear you
don't have mechanical sensors anymore
so i i think that in that point i saw
that the there is a huge amount of money
being spent because of the complexity of
developing
advanced autonomous platforms and that
drive really high production cost and a
very long time to the market and
actually
after that when it's
already in the field the warranty cost
and the the maintenance costs um um
increase
um opposed to that i'm looking at
manufacturers that they see low
controllability along the vertical
manufacturing process and then no one
guarantees to us
the driver that the electronics
reliability will actually maintain its
characteristics um in the field when
we're driving it
um so that was my turning point and and
my passion point um at that point
looking on the next stage um of making
cars better
interesting so you're at that
intersection and
for the next opportunity that you're
going to join are you approaching it
with this understanding are you
discovering you know this gap and this
issue after you join it well how you
know how how does this
this thing happen
so
that
when i'm looking at that at that point i
already knew
certain problems in the market looking
from both application side and both
system and electronic side and both
understanding what the oems would like
to see in the future
and at that point i see a very
interesting change in the market going
from vertical integration to more of a
triangle approach where oem's actually
starting to look into chips
um it was post corona and
we had a major crisis in in chip
supplying um and now oems would likely
have better control better involvement
in the process both in design and both
building new architecture inside the car
right basically their backward
compatibility today
needs to change
um and i see
warranty costs going dramatically and
car equals goes dramatically so that was
the point we saw that the problem we saw
the vector and since that point it
really evolved um to a very known
problem um
in the market right today
so within that company you know you're
solving a big point a big problem you're
understanding you know the complexities
that are non-trivial and they're not
frankly they're really not intuitive for
for somebody that's coming outside of
this industry
you know what is it like first you know
transitioning back to into a startup
mode
uh and taking a leadership position
there but but being in that mindset is
again you know after you know being in
mobile and being with
being with samsung and you know what
type of you know leadership style do you
have to develop that may be differently
from your previous experiences
so
i i think that um
from challenging perspective that's
definitely one of the hardest challenges
that they've done like every vertical
product today in the market and it
requires
the ability to translate what you know
into actual products um
so in protantics basically what what we
want to do today is to allow those
electronics in the simple words to
communicate with us during both the
production and using the in in the usage
in the field
and to tell us what hurts them and how
they feel from like the deepest level of
electronics before a failure possess
like an elementary threat i would say to
the safety
of the driver and if you want to
simplify it you can look at it as a
digital sensor as a camera that if you
rotate it it has eyes
into the electronics and basically it
produces data
all the time from within the car to the
cloud
and this data is super valuable both to
make manufacture better and both
maintain
the characteristic of those electronics
in the field and create better
trade-offs of those design
where new as a driver eventually needs
to spend
the time not fixing the car driving a
car that is 100 available um and 100
safe um in the field and it needs to
survive like that for 10 years um um in
the road so
that point requires that combination
between knowledge what's going on in the
market where the market is going and how
um the car industry is going to to to
change in and evolve and it's like
working together it's an ecosystem that
feeds each other and and and uh and
evolved together i would say
now
i think that you know
looking at the market today and if you
ask most people what is the most
challenging part of the ecosystem you
would say it's talent right it's finding
the right talent now i'm imagining
especially in the deep tech startup is
the one that you're that you're you know
leading here
it's it makes it it makes it even harder
because the pool of people that you can
potentially hire is also smaller but you
know i can only imagine also that part
of the hiring process is the brand of
the company but also you know the the
mission behind the company and the
ability to really engage with that
mission
is it hard to sort of sell on a company
that is sort of that is a little bit
more complicated i would say in terms of
its offering and in terms of the problem
that it solves because you require both
an understanding of the automotive space
but also of the chip market and what's
happening with autonomous vehicles as or
as vehicles you know become more and
more
advanced
yeah so
um first of all the answer is global yes
um i would say not specifically um
looking at us as a startup but globally
talent acquisition is is is hard we're
producing less r d um talents um today
and um
but if i'm personally looking at
protantics protantics basically evolves
from the market of of of data center and
communication
and um it already served uh uh very
important very big customers and the the
product was already silicon proven so
we'd be actually
able to to to look at what they've done
and and and see the the success criteria
already in in day one
um
so it was from perspective of looking at
it and and putting talented around it
and also um
um using talented uh person that worked
with me in the past it was um
i think at that point the vision
was pretty straightforward to what it is
that we're doing today
and most of the guys especially in the
automotive are very experienced guys um
so and very talented we have also a
region in in germany to be located
um close to the uh to the oems
but uh it's a it's definitely a
challenge from uh from headcount
perspective i would say yes
what do you enjoy most about your work
about your day-to-day about the industry
so
i think that um
the the most enjoyable part so if you
look at the
on the micro level um doing startups is
always hard um but when you see the big
picture
um
i think most of the uh
the fun that comes out of that is
actually to see how it grows and how it
grows with you both
as a team that work together and both
from product perspective
and also um
when i'm trying to look forward i'm
personally um as my hobby i'm defining
the act of you know driving as the
communication between our sensors
hearing feeling and it's like reflected
very accurately through wheels and
pedals to you and that what makes a
great uh car
the ability to reflect things
authentically around that box to you as
a driver
but now when i'm looking at the new
drivers um there is a new digital
audience
that just want to reach a destination in
the most efficient way and the most
accurate way and they are right and
rightly so
um but they are dependent on those
machines under 100 availability on the
zero failures
and what i'm fascinating is actually to
see
how the car driving lovers would fix
cars in the future with a laptop instead
of a torque wrench
and this is the
uh
the macro uh
looking at things on the micro on the
micro level you are very busy
um
in execution i i would say we're very
execution driven and this is also my uh
my way of managing things i love it i
love it
no
where so being a figure
in the industry now where you're
thinking about the future and you're
imagining the world where people are
fixing their cars through the laptop
not with the ranch like you did as a kid
where do you get that inspiration from
on a daily basis the inspiration to to
innovate to be creative to lead in this
in this view more futuristic state of
mind
so
i i think that
there is a lot of influencer today in
that that market back then in the in the
early days that we only started looking
at that market was very tiny and small
market today it's a huge consumer um
also for electronics
and it um also um accompanies with lots
of people and lots of very interesting
people that pushes boundaries um with
very good intention to to make good
and i also look at that as the the
the interesting part for me to do things
that actually
um makes good um
in the future and in our future in my
small domains called uh cars and and
autonomous driving i would love to keep
doing um that and
i was very fascinated by that i love it
if you had to think of a few words that
represent gal carmel
what what what words come to mind
um very tough question
i think that the first one will be
extremists in every aspect that i do
second will be
very analytical
and i think the third one will be
personal and emotional to what i do i'm
taking things
very light and very
seriously all all together um
and i'm doing things with lots of
emotion um
in it and a lot of passion um in it
thank you very very much thank you for
the great work that you're doing for the
industry and i love the intersection of
deep technology with you know consumer
behavior and throughout this
conversation you're not just talking
about cars and chips and data you know
data science but you're talking about at
the end how the people are going to
experience their drive and they're going
to experience the relationship with the
car and i love that and and you know
your journey is so interesting and
inspiring so thank you for sharing the
time with me and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you very much of course thank you
you